好 九月的話呢
還有所謂的蘋果新機發表會
以前都說了無心意
但這一次加入了折疊機會不一樣嗎
盤面上今天平蓋股是厲害到不行
除了光學
其實散熱跟這件事情也有關
這邊來請教漢文哥了
今天大概就是尾盤這個MSCI
真的往上拉
讓大家覺得挺開心的
也把量稍微拉出來
那你一直長期幫我們追蹤記憶體
可是很多人說
為什麼萬千重愛指給納雅科
有沒有其他的選擇
那今天光學當然是最強的族群
板材跟散熱也都沾到蘋果光
對啊 因為我覺得很久沒有講瓶蓋骨
但最近真的不太一樣了
那我們首先來看一下
今天整個記憶體的狀況
第一個就是MSI的尾盤的記錄調整
那第二件事情是大家追蹤到
最近的現貨價格持續在上漲
那因為美銀最近出了一個報告
他說以這個8月27號上禮拜為止的
不管是16G的DDR5
DDR4到DDR4的還有這個NET
你可以看到整个年增成长非常可观
真的很可观
都不想要采买的人真的好痛苦
对 尤其是大家会发现到
16GB的DDR4
现在价格是91美元
超越DDR5
所以这就代表说
为什么乃雅科是全世界最强的记忆体
因为它主要是做DDR4
所以目前整个涨价幅度
维持在高涨的状况
对乃雅科来讲是有利的
那我们可以看到
美银对这个9月份的预估
它说现货价格
预计在这个基础上面
再涨10%到20%
对那我觉得就代表说
目前记忆的事况
看起来是超级周期延续的时间
比大家想要来得更久
那我们大致上可以看到
今天整个台国的记忆体的表现
那刚刚提到的嘛
其实因为现在已经进入到
9月份面就9月1号了
陆续要公布所谓的8月营收
那我们可以看到
记忆体相关的
从制造IC跟模组
整个7月营收
这个区块全面都红通通
因为几乎全部都创下历史的新高
那8月份刚看到现货报价又在创高了
9月份合约价也会在涨
所以理论上来讲
你大概在今年的第三季
制造IC跟模组
他们营收继续创高机会非常的高
所以如果以现在情况来看
今天盘面上其实台股是跌的
但基础股票里面大部分都收涨
虽然说没有像这个光学镜头
那么样的一个激情
但整理上来看
我觉得代表说整个资金
慢慢有回流的迹象
那当然当中大家观察指标就是你可以看到製造當中納科最強因為它上半年賺了23.38然後IC設計當中金融座最強因為上半年賺了27.58
還是有倫理的是不是
因為剛剛正想問你說
大家基本面都很好啊
怎麼分還是有差啦
對 大家就優先買這個業績最好的
那如果以模組廠來講的話
群聯它也是賺最多
187.43
目前的位階或整理型
來看群聯看起來
也是整理得比較漂亮一點的
所以我们来看一下相关的一个现行
目前来看当然拿尔科是这个全世界记忆体之光
都在创新高的路上太厉害
对因为今天他收盘价543块
刚刚好也收到历史的新高价格
所以你对比到如果大家去看美光三星海力士
他们都在季线下面
那只有拿尔科一马当先往上冲
我觉得刚刚提到的
第一个他有台塑集团的加持
第二件事情
因為最近的法蘭籌碼
土洋同買大戶在那買方
所以我覺得籌碼的優勢搭配
台灣的特色是
每個月公布營收
所以有這樣的一個營收加持
記憶體的特性就是說
你好像撐過一個月
又有一個營收公布的利多
所以每個月都有一個期待性
那現在的情況我覺得
NARC就是
他其實雖然說
你會覺得好像短線上
來到相對高點
但你會發現到
他跟月季線的乖離並沒有很大
所以這個就代表說
如果未來再做一個
比較積極的補量
应该它还有在往上攻高一波
那整理上来看南亚科这一波
股价比较温是因为
国际大厂没有涨
所以我觉得如果说在
美光三星海力士
他们毕竟已经整理三个月了
如果九月份他们股价
能够开始反弹的话
对南亚科或说对华邦店
这些所谓机体制造厂来讲
比价现在会推升得比较快一些
我懂了
我们有全市就最强南亚科
但其他人就可能要等到
比如我们落后的这些
韩国美国厂上来
大家就会一起跟了
对 因为职场还是要有伦理
人家赚的比较多 他们没有涨
那南雅克自己涨就有点说不过去
所以我们就派华邦店
望宏林建中比较弱势来代表
那华邦店我觉得它优点在于说
你可以看到这边形态整理的差不多
军阶就比较多头排列了
那现领的部分
因为今天M4在做一个补量的动作
所以我觉得其实你可以看到
如果它这个月季线
已经开始到黄金交叉往上
也代表说这个量
如果能够维持一段时间的话
它股价毕竟以前两家是差不多
它創高它會跟著創高
現在華邦店已經大概
五月 六月份創高之後
將近三個月沒有創新高了所以我覺得大家可以期待是華邦店接下來有沒有一些補償的動能那當然因为两个背后的妈妈不太一样对 台座集团特别强那华星集团特别弱华星集团加油
这是两集团之争
对 面子之争
所以当然我觉得华邦店可能需要
后面集团不管被动元件
不管是它后面相关的一些PCB股票
也能跟长的话
也许华邦店的一个动能会变得更强
那接下来大家也可以看到
像在所谓的群联跟金豪科
群联真的我想很多的
像很多的官僚朋友都說
貨令已經好成這樣了
然後潘董也到處去宣揚自己躲好了
到底為什麼不漲呢
對 因為他還沒來這裡
所以他就沒有漲到
也許他有可能
那我們就看到群年的部分
你可以看到他也陷阱也做好了
他現在所謂的季線跟月線
即將在最近出現黃金交叉
所以眾多架構開始改變了
那最近你可以發現到
這邊有一個大量
那個大量是所謂的
公佈這個第二季的季爆利多
爆量長黑K棒
那我覺得它只要過這個大量高點
這邊量也出來
代表量價也開始出現
結構上的轉變
那群年的缺點還是在於說
投信真的不喜歡它
所以我覺得大家可能要期待
群年有強勢的上漲的話
投信的買盤要回來
那如果投信買盤沒有回來的話
你看外資雖然有買
這是被動性的買盤
那可能我覺得就要回歸到
它理論上來講
8月營收應該也會創下歷史的新高
所以那個營收利多
能不能推升股價
越过大量黑黑的高点
我觉得就决定到
台湾相关比较弱势的模组厂
有没有一个龙头老大
在做一个带涨的一个动作
那另外一个
IC设计就有金浩克的代表
创历史新高也是蛮猛的
对因为整个基体当中
除了南尔科创历史新高
金浩克也跟着创历史新高了
也代表说来到第四季
有这种所谓的
记忆体的业绩加持
又有IC设计背景的一个公司
好像就有本一笔
享有比较高的一个状况
所以它上半年赚了27块
那加上下半年会慢慢的
这个获利会慢慢递减
对 但我觉得整体上来看
因为它本益比就是比较低
所以我觉得就有这样的一个
推升的空间
那当它已经来到历史新高的话
你对爱普 对于预创来讲
我觉得就有一些轮动比较
这三张股票我觉得
目前现行都做得还蛮漂亮的
那江浩科 但今天创高之后
大家可以看一下
这个就不是法人的股票
比较偏向主力的股票
所以如果你手上有的
就严无限做
如果你没有的话
你就观察一下
过高之后
如果拉回到無線附近
我就可以做一個低檔的承接那另外看到今天比較整齊的是在瓶蓋股好 萬萬沒想到我们现在竟然会有苹果光重现江湖这样的状况因为以前大家对苹果新品发表就长得这样
那也没有什么好像特别需要讲的
但我觉得今年比较差别的地方在于
因为股价有创高了
所以大家会发现到
苹果股价今年表现比辉达更好
对 那台湾的瓶概股
很多党现在都创到历史的新高
所以似乎在瓶概股的部分
它就有这样的想象空间存在
那要跟大家讲惯性
9月10号以前
通常苹果股会有一个拉升的效果
那发表会出来之后
大家觉得
iPhone 18就长这样
手机就长这样
所以就有点失望性的卖压
所以往往过往
惯性是苹果的新品发表会之后
苹果本身跟苹果股
容易出现股价拉回
但后面除了业绩存长
可能有新一波的一个动能
那我们大致上来扫一下
这次要发表什么
iPhone 18 Pro Pro Max
那当然就是有更快的晶片
更好的拍照
然后更强的AI
今年Siri会有一个
比较好的功能的发表
那尤其是今年
因为换了一个新的CEO
所以会不会有一个新人
新气象
对硬体对软体的一个整合更好
我觉得应该会给他一点面子
好 所以我们来看一下
今天这个相关的平概股
其实表现就有点红通通
除了台积电本身来讲
今天是有点拉尾盘上来
但是你可以看到光学镜头
其实最近恒德年在创新高
真的好厉害
大力光從5000 6000 7000 快8000
對 那玉金光也是一樣
來到1000塊
以前大家覺得玉金光
好像六七百就上不去了
現在1000塊了
那折疊機的部分
可以看到新日新跟富士達
富士達也創造了歷史的新高
也很難得
然後到三二 齊紅 雙紅
齊紅 歷史新高
雙紅也接近新高
到今天的一個所謂軟板族群
華通跟台俊
那當然組裝代工
還是比較溫吞一點
但我們可以很快掃一下
這些相關個股
那首先看到这两个光
你看8月17号讲也没多久
半个月而已
就已经涨了五成
这也是快五成
这个两光已经不两光了
对因为如果只是平盖国的话
是不能涨这么多
对那还好他们有CPU的光通讯
所以这个光的加持
我觉得比较多的是光通讯那个光
而不是苹果光的光
但我觉得他们最少就是因为
他们有平盖国的底子
所以这两家公司在起涨之前
大概光本益比在二几倍
玉金光不到20倍
那現在兩個拉下去之後
都在三四十倍的本益比了
所以代表目前本益比偏高
但因為跟這個聯亞
跟文貌跟全新比較起來
〔此段辨識失敗，約 10:00 起〕